well CBS News has learned that the theft
of thousands of gun parts and some guns
from the ATF is now the subject of a
nationwide investigation ATF officials
still do not know the full scope of the
crime but say the stolen weapons pose a
risk to public safety the guns and parts
were supposed to be destroyed in a
facility in West Virginia Jeff the gates
broke this story and joins us now from
Washington Jeff good morning good
morning ATF officials say they have now
recovered a significant number of stolen
firearm parts and guns but our sources
are telling us there are many more left
on the streets and now lawmakers on
Capitol Hill are demanding answers from
the agency they want to know when ATF
leadership became aware of the theft of
these weapons investigators believe the
guns and gun parts were stolen from this
ATF firearms disposal facility in
Martinsburg West Virginia Philadelphia
police recovered a stolen part from an
agents Glock handgun in early February
when ATF officials ran a trace on the
item they discovered it should have been
destroyed at the Martinsburg facility
but it wasn't officials then launched a
criminal investigation determining that
thousands of firearm parts including
guns and ammunition had been stolen and
what they believed was an inside job the
thefts raised questions about how the
ATF secures weapons and ammunition that
it's supposed to be destroying Michael
Sullivan is a former ATF director some
confident of ATF would say there was a
failure in their process a failure in
their system in a letter to the ATF
deputy director senators on the Homeland
Security and Governmental Affairs
Committee asked the agency to turn over
information on the theft Michigan
senator Gary Peters the top Democrat on
the committee wrote the letter there was
a breach these parts were able to get
out and to be sold and that's something
that we can never tolerate one arrest
has been made so far in this
investigation police arrested a
contractor who worked at that facility
after finding a stolen pistol in his car
for now security has been stepped up at
the West Virginia facility and access in
and out of the building is being
controlled Gayle all right thank you
Jeff